I decided to be a responsible citizen
the other day I thought I should get
this the new booster shot and this is
the uh the latest Omicron booster you
heard about this yeah no
huh you haven't
Jesus anyway you heard of covet I know
about covet I didn't know there's a new
one okay it's the latest one and I
thought well I'm gonna be traveling East
you know we're going to be doing
podcasts there and big shows coming up
uh on the east coast and I thought I
should uh I should go get that so I I
made an appointment and I went to a CVS
this is not an ad I just wanted to get
the word out you said it's so aggressive
this is not it by the way this is not an
ad I'm just saying but you were like CVS
well whatever it's just very I respect
all businesses you don't want to upset
any major companies you've said it on
this podcast before even when not being
uh paid or compensated I just wish to
boost really the American industrial
engine that's just me how do you feel
about Enron I think it was a company
that was doing its best
if some accounting errors were made I'm
sure they've straightened it out how
they doing now they must be back on
track oh yeah they're they're gone okay
well I'm sure they'll be back soon and
when they are and Ron I'm here to get
the word out anyway I don't know how you
guys would have handled this but I'm
sitting outside this they said have a
seat sir and I said well you know Conan
O'Brien it didn't seem to get me
anywhere he said sir please you're
making a fuss I have a seat door open
and this young woman who had just
recently become a pharmacist just
recently graduated from pharmacist
school she uh invited me in and the sit
down answered all the questions and then
she said okay let's do it and I sort of
put on the gun show you know what I'm
saying I pulled up the my left arm and
she said okay let's do it and she jabbed
me and it was fine and then she said hey
how about getting the flu shot at the
same time do you want to do that and I
said sure now since then I've heard
other people say I don't know if you
want to get those at the same time I did
that at the same time oh you did for my
first booster yeah oh okay I said sure
I'll do it and she said other arm and I
said no same arm I think I was trying to
impress her I think so it sounds like
you're just kind of showing off well I
just wanted to I was like oh I want to
be a tough guy here did you at all go
like you know what give me two flu shots
get three boots give me three of those
omicrons give me three omicrons and uh
deworm me no
no anyway I got a second I got the other
one right in the same arm I think
practically in the same place man it
hurt oh really yeah because I got them
both on the same arm in the same place
and an hour later I was dead that's the
end of the story who's this guy then I'm
a ghost
wait why did you say when she said do
you want it on the same arm why did you
say yes you knew what was gonna happen
did you really think that you were gonna
like impress this young person I did I
think she was gonna say you're wow
you're a real man's man yeah what was
her reaction do you think she was
impressed no not at all she's like this
guy's stupid this is the question I
asked to see if people have any Common
Sense yeah but then I really kept I did
keep doubling down I'm like what else
you got I really did I wanted to do
something that where she would go back
to the other people that she had just
graduated pharmacy school with and say
man this guy came in today and he got
the booster in the left arm then he got
the flu shot in the left left arm I just
kept wanting more so I said what he got
some polio there
I said well I think he would have had
the polio shot probably when you were
born in the 40s and I said well I want
more of the polio I wanted more and more
and more but I was shocked I have to say
I was kind of I don't know did you have
a reaction at all when you had your uh
mild but I had this weird thing for
years of my life I would get multiple
allergy shots in my arm twice a week and
so yeah I know I know terrible to laugh
at that why are you laughing and not you
I don't know what's happening
can I say something yeah I was going to
laugh but Sona laughed so quickly and so
hard that it it snuffed out my laugh I
see it so wait a minute why did you have
to have so many shots to add bad
allergies but the point is that now
what's weird is I get kind of phantom
allergy pain so I get my shots in the
other arm and then the right arm starts
to hurt because I have all this when
people lose a limb when people lose a
limb they have Phantom limb pain and you
have Phantom allergy pain hey do you
ever have Phantom wedgie pain yes you do
too yeah oh yeah oh sometimes I relive
that wedgie those those Hooligans gave
me I give them some Wet Willies too
Phantom
with Phantom wedgie Phantom allergies
come on I don't really have all this
scar tissue in the arm from these
allergy shots and so somehow it triggers
it I don't know if it's psychosomatic or
what but what were you allergic to dust
mites and then everything else but that
was
so is that why your mother was
constantly dusting around you just
constantly no she never does it's
probably why Winifred remember Wellford
thank you son please when Winifred no no
please please
you're just making her name different I
have incredible powers
it's funny when Wilford uh Wilford
no I'm not I really don't know but when
Winston came by I remember that she had
a big feather duster and she kept
dusting you I didn't realize that was
left over from childhood
my point is but are you do you still
have allergies today just learn to live
with them okay yeah so you have all that
scar tissue for nothing
a pretty badass huh
oh I can't actually say these people
giving you shots when most guys have a
scar it's like on their face yours is in
a very well concealed part of your arm
and it's from allergy shots and it's
probably like hidden by some gross mole
and you remember where my scar is which
is equally embarrassing yeah it's on my
calf yeah from the tuna fish can it was
sticking out of the trash bag my mother
made me haul when I was wearing short
pants so you and I have you and I have
equally embarrassing scars oh speaking
of moles I now call my daughter the mole
keeper because she tries to take moles
off people like like scrape them off and
pick them off isn't that disgusting do
you think she's like poking fun or
making no I think she wants to be a
dermatologist
does she try to eat them afterwards she
hasn't gotten anyone off yet but no if I
manage to get a mole off of someone I
would I would just be so obsessed with
them popping at my mouth really I just
would I know you've gotten molded the
dermatologist do you want to eat them
feel how dare you oh I'm sorry how dare
he was my personal assistant reveal that
I've had to have a mole removed no one
is surprised no no one is surprised that
you'd have to have moles removed how
many moles would you save had removed
because I've had
dozens I haven't had moles removed I've
had uh little skin tags you know because
my parents didn't know about sunblock
okay of course it wasn't invented when I
was a child but um I've had if you if
you weighed all of the flesh that's been
removed by a dermatologist from my skin
it'd be over you could make another
person that's what you can make like 140
I say my doctor was building it look at
my back
oh man
that's like when the Elephant Man drops
his robe that is not to go out on video
that is just for audio you hear me oh my
god I've had two moles
and you lift it up
then in the Bible if Christ encountered
you he'd be like I'm not going now
doesn't it look like I got shot with a
shotgun on my back it does yeah yeah
that was uh incredible so what I'm
saying is my daughter's always after me
she's always trying to get at me yeah
she's trying to help you
do you ever do you go shirtless at the
beach uh yeah but I use heavy Sun cream
why are you are you giving him a complex
now it's okay oh no that should not be
seen I mean I'm not trying to give you a
complex I'm just for your own sake that
should not be seen that was uh that's a
horrifying Pablo
it's like a raw chocolate no it's like
you've saved your platoon by jumping on
nine grenades backwards
I'm sorry that's what it looks like and
because of that I'm alive in here today
yeah save 75 people's lives
you're in the trench all these grenades
flew in and you said hang on fellows
time to the rescue check off your shirt
and you Dove backwards onto the grenade
and we're blown 7 500 yards into the sky
desperately looking for paper in the bed
don't tell me where to wrap we're gonna
rap after I'm done with short stories
I've got your back turned into the
biggest freak show I've ever seen
good God
chased by villagers with torches all the
time
oh Lord
good God okay well anyway I hope you're
better soon I hope you're better I'm
fine I'm better because of it
I hope you're better all right well let
me I've never been happier that this is
not a visual medium
uh listener you've been spared that's
all I'll say uh it is funny now that
people are gonna think I have this like
grotesque mutilated back that's not that
bad it's not
when you finally see it it's not that
bad
all right let's all go and cleanse our
minds